Every night i dreamed the same dream
then
the nightmare begins
i did what i had to do
to protect our world you cannot
control everything strange
you open the doorway between universes and we
don't know who or what will walk through it
wanda what do you know about the multiverse this
had his theories he believed it was dangerous
he was right
i'm sorry stephen
your desecration of reality
we should tell him the truth
things just got out of hand
you break the rules look out
and become a hero i do it i become the enemy
that doesn't seem fair
Welcome back everyone this will be
my full doctor strange multiverse of
madness trailer video for the super bowl
they just released a bunch of new footage
confirming x-men in the mcu
now through the multiverse
patrick stewart's professor x is officially
back should we tell him the truth mild shot
there's so many things to talk about so many
easter eggs we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel i'll be doing videos for
all the other super bowl trailers that marvel and
everybody else releases i'll just start with the
good stuff first all this multiverse x-men stuff
they're bringing into the mcu the big thing
here is they confirmed that they're doing a
multiverse version of the illuminati with a bunch
of variants so they're just basically using the
multiverse explainer for some of the core x-men
characters in the mcu the whole idea here is that
when baron mordo in the trailer says your crimes
against reality can't go unpunished he arrests him
we actually find that he's a version of mordo
either he's the mcu mortal or he's a variant
who's on that multiverse illuminati team but he's
the one that cuffs him in those special cuffs and
takes him to face the illuminati now they don't
reveal everybody that's on that team all the
variants that we're going to see from different
universes but there's six chairs so that means
there are six members of the illuminati in the
mcu now we know patrick stewart's professor x
is one of them and this version of baron mordo
is another one so there are four other members
in the comics the other core members were iron
man black panther reed richards mr fantastic from
the fantastic four a version of captain america
black bolt namor and doctor strange himself there
were rumors that an iron man variant was going to
appear in the movie played by a different actor
so he could be one of these other members pretty
high likelihood now there were rumors that john
krasinski was going to have a cameo scene as a
variant of reed richards from another universe
he could be one of the other members there's
still two other spots and we know that neymar
is supposed to be a big villain in black panther
too so namor could be one of the other members
and then the last chair could actually be
a multiverse version of black bull there
been rumors that they would somehow reference the
inhumans so if you're really hoping that they redo
a good version of the inhumans in the mcu this
is your best chance also for those of you wanting
them to do a live action version of captain carter
from what if her shield appears in the poster for
doctor strange multiverse of madness they just
released a couple minutes ago so that confirmed
she's going to be in the movie she could also be
one of the other members of this illuminati team
the other big thing here is it looks like they've
taken over ultron's technology because it's these
ultron bots that are escorting dr strange to
face the illuminati but they look like completely
different versions of ultron robots we have to
assume that this version the illuminati from the
multiverse is way more op than the original comic
book version but the comic book version was meant
to be like the final say of all the most powerful
marvel superheroes coming together to deal with
the biggest biggest problems affecting earth so
this multiverse version is more powerful than them
it would just be absolutely crazy either way i'm
sure that deadpool will have something to say
about this because we know ryan reynolds deadpool
is coming into the mcu he's just like the other
big multiverse version of the character from the
fox marvel universe that we know is coming back
they'll probably be others too that they'll
reference we also have a confirmed scarlet
witch variant in the trailer in confirmed
scarlet witch villain so our mcu scarlet
witch seems like she's the one that's playing the
villainous role here i do it i become the enemy
it doesn't seem fair there are a bunch of
different realities too when they're intercutting
with this dialogue so i'll try to point out when
we're in different universes because everything
is kind of bleeding together and you have doctor
strange and america chavez just going through a
bunch of different realities but rewinding to the
beginning of the footage dr strange talks about
waking up every night having the same nightmare
and it sounds like reality is collapsing and it
has something to do with what happened at the
end of spider man no way home but when he says
i did what i did in order to save our reality
and you see him messing with chaos magic in the
dark hole that's what this book is in all these
different spheres where he's weaving this spell
it seems like those different spheres represent
different universes different versions of earth
and it sounds like he's weaving this spell
to try and fix any lasting lingering effects
of what happened to the end of spider-man no
way home with reality breaking down around them
because of the spell going wrong but they say that
whatever he did with chaos magic open the door to
the multiverse they don't know what's going to
come through wanda obviously scarlet witch going
to be one of the big villains of the film there
is a version of shuma gorath that they're calling
gargantos in the film but i think we're all in
agreement that they're really going for shuma
gorath energy with this creature here there's
also a really hardcore looking magical being
who's going after america chavez forcing her to
open portals behind her to other universes i think
i know what's going on with that i'll talk about
in a second but you see doctor strange himself
when he's talking about his nightmare he's walking
through a bunch of different versions of sanctums
you see reality bleeding around him it looks a
lot like the what if doctor strange episode where
doctor strange supreme goes completely off the
rails and winds up just completely fubaring his
entire reality to try and bring christine palmer
back but you see him walking through a couple
different versions of sanctums here these seem
like the sanctums that belong to some of these
other doctor strange variants that we see so we
have our doctor strange we have doctor strange
supreme or evil doctor strange however you want to
think about him there's defender strange based on
the defenders comic book version of doctor strange
and that different costume with the ponytail
and now at the end of the trailer there's
an even different version with a slightly
different looking costume with some red accents
that's weaving all this really crazy looking dark
magic with these dark spirits coming out of him he
seems like a different version of doctor strange
who's even worse but re-watching the trailer a
couple times i think he might just be the same
evil doctor strange and this is just a full look
at his costume in color because on the poster for
the movie there's only three different versions
of doctor strange there's also two versions
of scarlet witch on that official poster so i
think these two versions of scarlet witch are
the only two versions we see in the movie it's
almost hard to tell which one seems worse like
this one seems kind of evil like she has blood
all over her face and she's fighting what looks
like a captain marvel variant but then we see our
version of scarlet witch from the mcu in her brand
new costume she got during one division acting
very evil when she's going after doctor strange
so i think our version is meant to be the
more villainous one and this other version
is just another one from another universe in what
looks like a version of westview like she's gone
back to her home in west view that she had with
vision looking for her children billy and tommy
but it sounds like they might be living with this
alternate version of scarlet witch just having a
happy life and she just completely breaks down if
you're a big fan of that netflix voltron animated
series voltron legendary defender they actually
ended that series with a scene exactly like this
where hagar becomes like the ultimate villain goes
to another universe to try and find a version of
her family that's still alive and it kind of goes
down the way it looks here like this version of
scarlet witch seems like she's unable to steal
billy and tommy from this version of scarlet witch
like she doesn't want to take them away from
their happiness it seems like they're happy here
if you ever wanted to see dr strange's bedroom
this is what it looks like when he's in his
regular street clothes talking to scarlet witch
about the multiverse she directly mentions vision
also when it seems like she's trying to trap him
later he's seen those same clothes so it sounds
like at some point during this conversation
there's a big twist and also i believe what's
going on here when there's this giant attack
on carmartage this is scarlet witch coming to
try and take america's chavez and force her to
open portals to other realities so that she can
find this other version of scarlet witch with west
view and billy and tommy i believe the way they're
explaining it is that scarlet witch in the mcu
even though she's super op with her chaos magic
cannot travel physically to other realities
other universes she can only do that with america
chavez's help and that's why america chavez is
so important to the plot of the movie also why
you see them forcing her here like she's trapped
and they're trying to force her to open portals
behind her here then you see doctor strange
in america chavez traveling through a bunch of
different realities like they're falling through
what looks like a version of prehistoric earth in
some alternate universe there's this dinosaur next
to them falling through if we're talking about
big x-men easter eggs maybe they'll do an easter
egg for the savage land i think the only really
unanswered questions are what's going to happen
to this multiverse version of the illuminati
will they continue to be a presence in the mcu
after this and if they're messing with reality
so much during the plot of this movie when they
fix everything by the end of the film will that
be the explainer for how a bunch of x-men mutants
show up in the mcu like in putting all the pieces
back together will some other things sort of cross
over the way we see patrick stewart's version of
professor x showing up in the trailer the funny
thing about him coming back too is that he said
that he talked to kevin feige a couple years ago
after they got the fox rights back and said that
he declined to come back because his ending in
the logan movie the wolverine movie was so good
that he didn't want to trample on that but i think
the way around that i think the way they convinced
him is by telling him that this is a multiverse
version of the character so no you're not coming
back is exactly the same version it's just a
little bit different with a huge twist the really
cool easter egg for this too is that the concept
art for him coming back his scene has him in one
of those floating chairs that looks exactly like
his chair from x-men the animated series which
they're also bringing back with new episodes on
disney plus next year so it was a really good time
to be an x-men fan just a marvel fan in general
they're kind of doing for x-men in this movie what
they did for versions of spider-man toby maguire
andrew garfield in the spider-man no way home
movie so do not be surprised if there are a bunch
of other special cameo scenes with other variants
of big avengers characters other x-men characters
even fantastic four characters there's supposed
to be some more marvel footage later tonight
other marvel super bowl trailers so i'll try to
do videos for everything make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss anything
and if you spotted any huge easter eggs in the
trailer that i didn't talk about in the video
just write them below in the comments everyone
click here for all my new super bowl trailer
videos i'll update the link as i post new videos
and click here for that brand new marvel x-men
teaser thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!